vous dites que vos spectacles actuels et
plus universel que que le précédent
moins autobiographique ouais vous régler
mes problèmes d'identité culturelle
même si vous restez balancé entre
plusieurs cultures faut quand même
marocaine québécoises et françaises
ouais quand vous étiez au québec vous
aviez l'accent du québec je n'avais pas
je le prenais pour pas pour marée mais
pour au début ça fait rire mais on
s'aperçoit vite que c'est plus très
drôle quoi ça va une fois que tu l'as
fait deux-trois fois venir juste un truc
pour me rappeler de julie snyder mais je
pense qu'à un moment donné quand tu
prend l'accent c'est quelque chose que
tu peux pour faire juste pour rigoler
besson baisse de
revenus est revenu sur ses pas fait et
non mais c'est moi je le lac sans je le
prenais pour que ça aille plus vite en
fait tu sais parce que quand au québec
tu demandes un truc avec l'accent normal
s'il ya d'abord un petit truc où il
percute que t'as pas l'accent québécois
et ensuite tu donnes le truc quand tu
arrives à te dis bonjour est ce que je
pourrais avoir dû laisser ça ça va plus
vite le dit alors je préfère je vois ça
va plus vite quoi tu aurais je pense
toujours à seysses et gad elmaleh
quittant le maroc et débarquant au
québec ça doit être une sphère vous en
effet un spectacle de canal serait
certain décalage c'était ça c'est ce
décalage culturel n'est pas que culturel
climatique aussi depuis quarante à -43
web chez les québécois depuis déjà
banalise on est drôle de pied
c'est vrai qu'à vannes à la première
fois je lui il m'a fait rire aussi un
noir avec l'accent québécois ça va
scotcher mois
donc vous allez olemps une interview
mais on est heureux je suis là
je fais même comme ça à regarder fait
comme ça on a fait le mec qui est
intéressé par ce que je dis oui et toi
tu dessines carrure et elle voit du
champagne mais elle boit du champagne
oui quand vous êtes allés au site une
envie d'aller aux états unis en fait il
a envie d'aller au théâtre tu peux me
dessiner un mouton
décidément trop siffredi caroline
donc engagé le mal aimé je continue avec
mes amis que les spectateurs parce que
je peux rien faire non là je suis là tu
es là viendrait donc quand vous allez en
amérique vous avez au canada oui c'est
parce que vous vouliez aller en amérique
mais comme ça par les français c'est
plus simple pour voilà voilà ouais
figeant 500 fois qu'on la lui pose c'est
vrai ça c'est pas du sénat répond jeu
mais je m'étalais dit voilà vous avez
compris ouais voilà non mais vous êtes
vraiment intéressés par les états unis
vraiment arrêter une date
entre sting non j'aime beaucoup les
états unis je suis fasciné par cinéma
américain et voilà vous avez un autre
amateur des états unis ici c'est jorian
avec les présidents américains nabe on
est ce que comme lui il est fasciné par
le côté impitoyable des états unis du
côté la réussite là les mecs qui
arrivent vraiment quoi est il dit gad
elmaleh en france on n'aime pas la
réussite
je dois répondre c'est vrai tu devrais
pas répondu commenté l'as tu es moment
là je dois commenter à ce moment là
c'est que je pense que je pense que les
l'idée du succès l'idée de célébrer le
succès elle n'existe pas beaucoup en
france et c'est ce qui fait du mal au
cinéma français ça me fait chier ça
m'emmerde quoi je me dis que l'on
pourrait ya des super film est super
acteur il ya des supers choses qui se
passent en france sauf que l'on dit
paille ou pis quand ça marche et ça
m'énerve c'est tout alors
c'est une vraie mission de décision là
tout le monde parle à tour de rôle tout
le monde a des avis sur les choses oui
moi honnêtement
je m'en fous
et 5 alors ça c'est le stade d'après
voilà c'est peut-être que j'atteindrai
ce stade là après midi là maintenant il
est là c'est tout c'est une sorte de
nirvana janvier on reviendra ici chez
vous genre une barbe de zaidi ravages
qu'ont fini
c'est vrai que là vous avez un gros ego
1 je crois
je vous adore 1 franchement car si cette
gentille alors oui c'est ce que j'aime
chez vous garde non je vous avais les
mêmes vieux que des avants
écoutez ça me fascine vo 20h
si vous pouviez vous coiffer comme
chouchou ça serait génial d'accord les
corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou